my name is Alistair and I'm here to talk
about writing an embedded operating
system in Rust
so
I thought I'd kind of start a bit about
myself I work in Western Digital
research and I've been working with rust
in in specifically embedded for a few
years now and so it's kind of what I
learned what I like about rust and and
the little bit I don't like about rust I
guess but
um just pre-warning I really love rust
so it's it's not not a lot of bad stuff
to talk about
Okay so
so I think
people probably know what rust is if
you're here but I couldn't tell if you
know how many people were using rust
every day how many people had just heard
about it and thought it was the next
great thing and and so I thought I'd
kind of talk about what it is and why
it's exciting
um and then go into the embedded part
so rust is a systems language so it's
similar to C in that regard so there's
there's no garbage collector there's no
virtual machine it's it's all compiled
down to Bear assembly
and it provides memory and thread safety
and that's probably a thing I hear the
most is that it's a safe language
and that's all done at compile time
and so that's I'll talk about that you
know for the next few slides and so it's
extremely powerful and it has great
performance and it's slowly being
introduced into open source projects so
I was at LPC earlier this week and there
are multiple sessions about using rust
inside the Linux kernel there's patches
on list and you know it looks like it's
going to happen
and to give you an idea of performance
there was an interesting talk at LBC as
well about rewriting the nvme driver in
the Linux kernel in Rust is this a great
experiment because the nvme driver is
ridden in C and it's not some like side
driver that no one ever cares about it's
used in you know pretty much every
laptop in this room is using nvme and
every high-end server is probably using
nvme and so it's extremely performance
and critical
and so it's currently written in C and
there are a lot of smart people all over
the world looking at it squeezing every
bit of performance they can out of it so
if Russ can compare to that you know
it's going to be good compared to some
like clunky driver that no one really
cares about and is slow anyway
and so the numbers from the outcome were
that basically rust was
in most cases about equal to C and the
worst case it was about two and a half
percent slower than the you know hugely
optimized C code so to give it to rust
is basically as much as performant as c
um and in this case as well the kernel
uses some auto-generated bindings and we
think that might lead to some of the
performance slowdowns and it's possible
Russ could overtake C because the
compiler actually knows more about the
code than the C compiler does
so rust is great but I mean why bother
switching right it's as good as C you
want to just stick with C C's worked for
so long you know I think everyone in
this room probably knows C why learn
something new
and the reason is because of memory
safety
so some people might say ah it doesn't
matter right I never write buggy code oh
my code that's a good response all my
code is perfect I've never ridden a bug
in my life
um I want to say it's wrong that's just
stupid but maybe you are amazing and
you've never ridden a line of bad code
but you probably work with someone who
does and you probably will leave the
project or inherited the project and
someone else will right it's it's just
unbelievable to say you're not going to
and I think these two statistics kind of
give that away so Microsoft and Google
Chromium or Google Chrome
uh heavily invested in right they're not
some like hobbyists working at night
these are huge projects with huge
software teams behind them doing fuzzing
reviews audits you know all sorts of
things and they say 70 of their security
bugs are memory safety issues
and so think about that security bugs
that's things that not just like the
color isn't right in the background or
something that's impacting users because
they're exposing them to malicious
attackers right and 70 are memory safety
issues so if we could fix that
that doesn't get us all the way there
you know we're not we're never gonna get
perfect but that's a good percentage of
security thick issues just kind of fixed
right if we can use a memory safe
language
and that's where rust really shines
so I kind of assume everyone here knows
C or is familiar with c
and so I wanted to start with how rust
is similar to see
so it's ahead of time compiled like I
talked about you use llvm in the rust
case to build assembly output
and it focuses on maximum programmer
control so unlike you know some
scripting language or something like
that you have full access to the
hardware there is nothing below there's
no jvm or anything like that your full
access and zero runtime overhead
it works well for bare metal torque
which is why I'm here it's statically
typed it has performance I just talked
about that and it's easy to link with C
programs so you can call C to rust code
and rust to C code so you don't have to
rewrite everything in Rust overnight you
can kind of replace bits and bits and
call into them
and it has the same basic kind of float
control
but how's rust different right if it's
the same why would we both are switching
so it's strongly typed much more than C
which is interesting it has this module
system so in C you know you have this
header and you have if if def something
underscore H then you define it and then
you and it gets clunky and you have all
these headers and you've got to split
them out and which ones you use rust
doesn't have that it's just modules you
just import you want to use this import
the module you have access to it and all
statements evaluate to values so you can
do like let variable equal if and then
have if if
else statements and you get a value back
um and what starts to shine with the
memory checkout is these references so
if you have a reference or a pointer you
have one mutable which means you can
read and write it or many e Mutual which
is read only and so this is how we start
getting the memory safety parts
and you think oh that's just like a such
an annoying constraint I can only have
one read access to this variable right
how can you never do anything like that
I think the more you look at it the more
you think that's all I do and see anyway
if you're passing around like pointers
that you're writing from multiple places
without you can do it in Rust with locks
and stuff if you're not doing that and
see you're just asking for trouble right
so these are things you do and see
anyway Russ just kind of makes you do it
has generics which I have an example on
as well macros in raster
complex everyone's ever looked at them
they're hard to get your head around but
they're much more powerful than C and
almost all of rust is a safe subset
through static analysis which is where
you get the memory safety and I'll talk
about the unsafe part later as well
so this is kind of an example of C code
and rust code it's on the left
we do there we go you know it's pretty
pretty simple I have a string I allocate
another string
copy from one to the other print them
and then I'm going to change the W from
a lowercase w to Alpha case w
through pointer accesses and so the rust
code looks pretty similar so I create a
mutable variable that means I can edit
it and rust variables of default read
only so you have to claim it as mutable
I'm going to print it
I'm going to get a pointer and then I'm
going to access the pointer here with my
you know adding offset into it and
access it so this is where rust is
different to see so we've got my my
pointer I'm adding six you know I'm
counting six characters in I'm D
referencing the value to get the
character
Bernie that's an unsafe operation and so
in Rust unsafe is
I think there's lots of different ways
of thinking about unsafe but the way I
like is you're not saying it's wrong
it's not bad it just means that you know
something that the compiler doesn't
that's what unsafe is so in the case of
embedded if you have a uart mmio region
right so you've read the data sheet and
the data sheet says if I write to this
address it's going to print something on
the you out and then in the rust
compiler doesn't know that so if you try
and write to that address it's going to
say oh that's dangerous what are you
doing that could seg fault that could
crash who knows what that's going to do
and so unsafe is you just telling the
compiler trust me I know it's okay if I
write to that address it'll print out it
won't crash and so that's what unsafe is
about
and the reason it's nice is because
generally in your program you only have
small amounts of unsafe so if you have a
team you can all review the unsafe code
much more thoroughly than you can the
entire program compared to C where every
single thing you ever do is unsafe Russ
you only have little Snippets hopefully
and that you unsafe and in reality as
well you don't actually use unsafe a lot
you kind of hide it behind helper
functions and wrappers so you don't ever
really write unsafe code
and then we do the same thing as C we
just set the lowercase w to an uppercase
W again it's unsafe because we're
accessing a broad pointer
so rust in embedded I guess that was the
topic of the talk
so rust has a strong focus on embedded
there's a embedded working group there's
embedded books there's all these things
I was telling someone earlier this week
about in better rust and they said oh
but why bother right isn't all the cool
rust features you know don't you need
high level things for that I think
people get confused I guess because
there's people think of rust as well and
it has these helpful
um you know like the vector so you can
create like a dynamically allocatable
array and and hash tables it has these
kind of helper functions that a modern
language would you would expect but that
c doesn't have
and this isn't a core part of the
language right the language doesn't need
that it's actually just a library on top
so rust has kind of three main libraries
the core library and that runs
everywhere that runs on your bare metal
system that runs on your posix computer
that works anywhere you want and that
has things like options and results but
not too much else then you have
allocator Library called live Alec and
that gets your vector and more complex
things like that that needs an allocator
so if you you know run on your computer
it works if you're running on a bare
metal system you can Implement your own
allocator and that will work or you can
say no I don't want an allocator you
know it's too high risk or too much work
and you just don't use that library and
then there's also the standard Library
the STD which is you know file open
network traffic stuff like that and you
need a real you know desktop class
system at that point
so the embedded rust project that I've
been working on is called talk so it
wasn't just written by me as you know as
a community of people
um and it's written in Rust it's all
rust uh it's not an atos but it is a
small embedded system so it's designed
for a system without an NMU so think of
your cortex M3 cortex m4s or your risk 5
you know rv32i type of systems
and it's designed to protect both the
kernel and applications it runs
applications from attacks
so this is a big diagram of how the
architecture works so down on the bottom
we have the hardware so it's an embedded
system we have a CPU you know r squared
c a spy that type of thing
then and this is you know it's not a
rust thing it's just any hardware it
doesn't matter
then we have our drivers so you can see
kind of the orange that's our drivers
and so we consider a drivers trusted so
they can use the unsafe keyword and this
is kind of by requirement right so the
driver can really do anything so it's
going to set up a dma and it's going to
copy you know your spy data and dma into
memory so if it's malicious or buggy it
can set the wrong DNA address and you
know delete your code so that's
inherently an unsafe thing and you have
to write that correctly
but then so that's considered trusted
and then we have the core kernel as well
with the scheduler a Process Management
it handles sys calls and it has these
Hardware interface layers which I have
in the next slide and that's also all
called trusted so again it can use
unsafe it's not a lot of unsafe but it
can it's it's by Design the core part of
the kernel and we have to trust it
and what gets exciting now is these
capsules so the capsules are untrusted
so all of this code is running in the
same Hardware level it's all running in
Secure mode in arm or or machine mode
and risk five
but using rust we can forbid unsafe in
capsules so that means the capsule where
we put all the logic and the complex
parsing doesn't have any unsafe code
so for example this is where you might
put your your ble stack or a
virtualization layer so for example we
have multiple applications and they all
want to print so they all CIS call in
and print then we have a capsule that
takes them and and puts them all
together and writes them all out to the
one you want
and that type of stuff is complex as
buffer management we've got to move
things around we've got to return errors
or return success values and all of that
is done in a capsule which is no unsafe
we forbid it in the language
and so this means if there is a bug in
there it's unlikely to be kind of a
memory safety issue where we you know
overflow a buffer or something like that
it's it's more like a logic error where
we return the wrong value or something
but we're not going to we're not going
to allow an attacker to you know
overflow our ble stack because they say
the size is five and we have a only a
two byte long buffer because rust will
catch that and rust will help us there
then we use the hardware
um to separate processes so processors
run in a different
um you know user mode uh yeah user mode
and risk five or untrusted on on arm and
we use Hardware like mpu and PMP to
enforce them and so they actually can't
do anything malicious so a user
application can be written anything or C
assembly rust it doesn't matter but they
are completely constrained by the
hardware and all they can do is system
call into the kernel even if a malicious
application wants to take down the
system by just while one and and use all
the CPU we'll preempt them eventually
and swap in other applications so no
application can take down the system and
we again try and offload as much logic
as we can there because again if that's
taken over or that crashes it only
affects one process instead of taking
down the entire device
so I talked before about talk Hills and
rust generics
I hope you can see that but on the left
hand side uh is a hill they're called
treats in Rust so it's just a pub treat
called hasha
hopefully you can see it uh called hasha
and it has a cons size so the output is
always going to be a constant and this
is kind of like a a header file almost
in C so we're saying these functions
exist and you need to Define them and
then we
um and while this is nice is because we
can use it to connect like the bottom
layer where those drivers are up with
the top layer where those capsules are
and so we can say this driver implements
hasher so it's going to accept all of
these functions and it will you know
handle them correctly and the capsule
can say I need a driver that implements
hasher otherwise I won't work and at
compile time we can ensure that the
drivers there and the capsules there and
everyone kind of understands what's
going on instead of you know looking for
weird function pointers and be like I'll
make sure this function pointer calls
here and what happens if it's not there
and not implemented and so rust it's
another way we can statically enforce
everything at compile time instead of at
runtime
and then on the right hand side is the
implementation
I actually screenshotted the wrong thing
but it's the same concept but it's
implementing that function so you know
we take a copy of ourselves we take some
data we
I can use this thing so it's in a
recording
so anyway if we're not busy then
we do the work and we can then modify
the registers so we're setting start
modifying you know clearing interrupts
enabling interrupts and then progressing
the data so it all kind this is the
unsafe code that's happening under here
we're you know reading and writing to
mmio addresses but it doesn't look
unsafe to us it just we're just
modifying values right and
so also so embedded so we need inline
assembly right we need we can't write
the entire thing in Rust we're going to
have to have some assembly code
and rust just handles that so here we
have an example of the startup code for
risk five so we can link it in the link
up we can specify where we want it we
call the function as a naked function so
it does so llbm doesn't generate any
prologue or epilogue for it and then we
just say as the same way in in GCC it
does in lvm that we have assembly and we
can write it out and this is some
poisonous there were this is some risk
five oh
I had some risk five assembly again it's
inside the unsafe keyword because the
game the compiler is saying look I don't
know what's in here it's up to you uh to
keep that safe and so there's a you know
a few hundred lines of assembly in the
entire project and you can heavily
scrutinize that read that it's very well
commented and then the compiler has to
trust you with the unsafe
so we also use I mentioned this a little
bit but because I also really like Risk
five I thought I just kind of throw it
in there we use risk 5 PMP which is the
memory protection to isolate the
applications so in Risk 5 we actually
can also apply this to the kernel so the
hardware is at all times enforcing write
or xor or execute so all memory is
either writable or executable it is
never both so the stack for example can
be read and written but can't be
executed so even if there's a bug in our
unsafe code or the rust compiler doesn't
catch something hopefully the hardware
then kicks in as well and makes it even
harder for an attacker to so you get
some so get some commands on a stack and
trick Us in executing them because
hopefully the hardware again will catch
us there
um and so then we do the same for
processes where we say you know process
can only out access its memory it can't
access anyone else's memory and then the
same thing read and write execute oh
sorry read write for you know it's stack
and stuff and read and execute for its
text
um oh so it's a little quicker I guess
but so that's the the kind of end of Why
roster so amazing
um and so I had a few pain points though
if anyone's kind of ever started using
rust but at least I found that I ran
into
so one is lifetimes I don't know if
anyone's done a lot of rust but you kind
of yeah I see some nodes you kind of
quickly run into lifetimes and this is
an example of you know it's really basic
function we're just implementing
something and basically cooling down to
the layer below it but you can see that
tick a and the tick a is just everywhere
and that's a lifetime a and so it's a
way of telling the compiler that as long
as you know how struck exists for this
long the buffer will also exist for this
long and then the client will exist for
this long
um so it makes sense and and when you
learn rust you kind of slowly understand
it but it one it's a hard thing to
understand coming from C and it just
looks kind of clunky and long and
there's this you know other examples of
scrolling across the page as there's
just so many lifetimes
um I don't really have an answer or a
specific complaint it's just kind of
annoying
um but one thing that you do really have
to be careful of with and better rust is
hidden panics
so rust has this concept of panics so
it's like an assert you can say you know
Panic unsupported feature
and in embedded you don't use them that
much but but maybe it's more if there's
something fully unrecoverable so maybe
you get a hard fault and you I don't
know what to do we can't really keep
going so I'm just going to panic I'm
going to print some information and and
exit
and if you specifically call it as a
macro called Panic then it's fine right
you understand what's going on you know
what's going to happen but Russ will
also put some hidden ones in and so an
example of this is an array access so if
you call an array like a buffer and you
iterate through it you'll do buffer you
know square brackets I and I is zero one
two three four five
and each one of those accesses rust no
is going to check that the array is
however long and your access is inside
that array if it's not inside if it's
outside rust or panic and so if you're
riding in a better kernel it's not great
that the user space can send
here's a fire by buffer I tell you it
has 10 bytes iterate through it rust
won't let you get a vulnerability
because it will panic but it'll panic
and your whole kernel dies and it's not
great for maintaining for reliability
but also in embedded is a huge amount of
code space because a panic is a string
and so now you have the string that
you're storing in there in your binary
that you have to look for
um and it's not clear or obvious when
you start doing this when you start
working with rust that it's going to do
this to you
um so you don't have to do it this way
there's a function called get and you
should you know write your buffer.get
and then I and that won't Panic that
will return a result and you can check
it and that way you won't get a bug and
you'll handle the result you know you
handle the error if you want to panic
you can Panic maybe you just return an
error to the application or something
but there's no easy way to catch panics
once you've built it and so this is
something that comes up a little bit
with the rust inside Linux work because
the same thing no one wants a Linux
kernel to crash when you pass user space
does something weird so there's no tools
at the moment but the hope is that there
will be improvements in the future oh
wait it'll print warnings or errors when
you're going to generate a panic from
something that isn't obviously a panic
so that's something really to keep an
eye out it's not obvious when you start
working on Rust
there's some overhead stuff like Dynamic
dispatch which is kind of like a V table
thing
um if anyone knows C plus plus t plus
has the same kind of problem but you
just have to be careful about how you do
it there are ways to write rust that you
don't get this but then normally the
code is more complex and confusing and
harder to follow
am I going to too much but if anyone's
interested there is an issue kind of
talking about all the trade-offs
and the other thing is virtual function
illumination so I don't know if anyone
knows C plus plus but it has the same
thing and there's again there's this V
table it's to do with because you I mean
simple plus is more like the object
orientated part in Rust it comes from
the traits I talked about four-way
implementing traits
and it becomes really hard for a Linker
to remove unused code and so we've seen
examples of you know you have this build
and in your debug build you have a
really helpful if there's an error just
dump all the CPU State information right
and you print it all out and that's
really great it takes up a lot of code
size because you have all these strings
and it's dumping them all out and then
you build the release mode and you you
don't want that so you just never call
the function but at the moment in Rust
the lto is not good enough so it won't
remove those functions so you'll have
functions in the final binary that can
take up a lot of space and never be used
so at the moment we have to use configs
which are like macros like fdfs and NC
to comment them out or remove them
but it would be nice if the rust
compiler gets smarter and can remove
them automatically
so that's it from me
um are there any questions or thoughts
uh oh yeah yeah I just have to read out
the question when you say that so yeah
yeah recoverable from uh there might be
an RFC for that okay so I said repeat it
for the recording so the the statement
was there is a it might be work on
panics that are non
did their recoverable appendix that are
recoverable yeah so I guess
I guess it depends though because
sometimes like there's some things in
especially in bed you can't recover
right like if you get a bus fault
and what do you do right you just kind
of have to just give up and say that's
an error uh maybe reboot but it's still
so I think there's different levels of
panics and it it'd just be nice if we
could you know turn them on and off
which things like um Zig do you can turn
like debug mode on and debug mode off
okay that's good oh so the state you're
saying there is work and rust for that
yeah
uh so the question was what other
compilation times compared to see
um
yeah
I hear a lot about people complaining
about rust compilation times but like
our final binary is very small it's a
embedded application it doesn't bother
me I think the compilation time issue
more comes from if you're building your
web server in Rust and it pulls in all
these different dependencies and crates
and you know you've got 100 dependencies
and and it's building them and then
building the final you know giant web
server that can be slow
but it normally builds and you know it
builds it under 20 seconds for me so
it's
and it does um it does cash right so it
depends what you edit but I don't think
it's very slow and embedded
clarify the funny thing so I guess the
user space
like a kernel and the kernel panic would
raise an exception and like a bug macro
in uh Linux kernel right so that way
it's unrecoverable because you're kind
of are exited your task and you never
know what to do is that correct
um yeah okay so I'm trying to repeat the
question too uh so the question was
about the panics and if in user space
calls an abort then it goes into the
kernel no so I guess my point was so if
you use a space panics I don't care
that's user spaces problem so if you if
an application panics
um it can tell the kernel I mean it
doesn't have to but it can tell the
kernel and the kernel can say okay you
panicked I'll restart you or I'll just
kill you or it doesn't matter I don't
care but if the main problem is if and
that doesn't affect reliability right if
one application panics it the others
keep running the problem is if the
kernel panics
um like like that buffer right so if you
have one of those buffer with square
brackets and the in the user space
passed it in and the user's face says
here's my buffer and it's only five
bites but you the user space tells you
it's 10 then the kernel will Panic on
accessing that
because
so well yeah I mean so rust won't like
you weren't actually doing invalid
access so yeah
yeah so Russell calls a bounce check but
that will call the Panic Handler so the
hardware won't trigger an exception but
in by restaurant time right like
re-implemented or overloaded or you so
yeah it's not overloading in Rust but um
but yeah I mean look like so for example
on top right so the Panic Handler is
implemented in talk and it will just
exit and print you out and like dump as
much State as I can over the UI so you
could I mean you can try and handle it
but you generally don't have unwinding
which is another thing rust has
um but you don't have unwinding and
embedded because there's nothing really
to unwind and code size is important too
so
I mean in debug mode overflow
called the Panic as well right and yeah
so in Rust I guess the question was in
in debug mode the Overflow would cause a
panic in Rust there's not really in some
a lot of that stuff there's no
difference between debug and release so
a release mode build will also Panic if
you overflow that buffer
um
it checks the Overflow in runtime yes
okay so
the comment was oh wow I'm worried about
the overhead
um yes but I think there's two ways to
look at it because
if if you aren't checking the length
size of your buffers and C at runtime
that you're getting from a user space
application you're also doing something
really bad so it Russ does the check for
you but you also do the check and see
anyway right like
oh to integer overflow uh there are
different there's there's ways to do
unchecked and checked integer overflow
you can do whichever one you want
depending on your situation
uh yeah
the overflows I mean if and the
mechanics Etc if you do the check
beforehand and handle that and return an
error to use the space
is the compiler small enough to know
that you already checked and doesn't
introduce the additional overflow checks
into the code yeah so the question was
if you do the check beforehand is the
compiler smart enough to know that you
checked and not do a check uh yes so
there's a few things you can do so you
can do there are unchecked ways to
access a buffer so if you you know
I wouldn't I don't think it's a good
idea but you could you know do the check
manually and then do the unchecked ways
and just ignore the checks but in the
experience I've seen if you do a check
the compiler will pick up that it's
already checked and it won't double
check again so you you can just use dot
get which is the like the good way to
get them
um in like index into array for example
and if you did a length check beforehand
the compiler will will remove all the
checks in the actual generated code
so you kind of lose all the overhead of
accessing it
yep
what's the status the actual set of the
project is it used anywhere already in
Hardware oh
yeah that's a good question so
um the question was if I've been talking
about talk is it used anywhere and
what's its status so talk is a open
source project it wasn't started by
Western Digital or anything but it is an
existing open source project
um
it
it has lots of interest at the moment
lots of people are looking at it the
Google open Titan project is using talk
I don't know if people know what that is
but
um that's a like a silicon open silicon
root of trust and they're using talk and
developing with it
um there are lots of academics and
Western Digital also contributing
publicly
uh like in production you mean no I
don't know if it's anywhere in
production
uh yeah
um you said that drivers use unsafe but
is that really needed can't you like for
mmio media
make you attendance the email IO and
then the drivers use that free yeah so
the question was drivers use unsafe is
that really needed uh can't you just use
a crate that does the MMA or access and
then not expose the unsafe yeah so that
that is what we do so so the actual
driver
generally doesn't have the unsafe
keyword in it there is a a wrapper below
that that does the unsafe accesses and
the driver doesn't have unsafe but the
idea is a driver is still allowed to
because sometimes
um like with dma it comes up every now
and then maybe this driver needs to do
something or maybe it needs to access
um sometimes is like this special config
you need to hit before you actually hit
these other ones and it's easier just to
do a raw pointer access so generally no
it's not a good idea but if we just
allow it well the capsules actually have
a rust language feature that says be
forbid unsafe so you can't turn it on
yeah I mean you can if you're debugging
sometimes you you know you delete that
but but an actual committed code and
it's you cannot turn it off so
uh any more questions
oh cool
oh yeah
VM and GCC and
the question was does rust have any
built-in you mean like um built-in
functions in lvm or GCC you mean like
the like the gnu extensions and that
type of thing is that what you mean
um
I guess that's a good question I don't
know again I mean it's only well so the
moment rust only uses lvm although there
is a lot of work on GCC front end as
well
yeah I don't know if they're ex they
probably use them internally but I don't
know if they're exposed in the way they
would be declaring
um into the rust compiler like the rust
language just is what it is it you know
if it's in there it's it's part of
language if it's not it's not there's I
don't think there's no like special
extensions you add they might be using
the llvm extensions under the hood
though I'm not sure
okay so if there's no more questions
then that's the end of my talk